parce qu'on a entendu monsieur jafar
elle vaut arrive mettre directement en
cause ce qu'il va y avoir d'autres
risques où figuraient que je vais
discuter avec jafar el-houari vous
croyez en trou nous soit dit que vous
n'avez pas assez et déjà hier vous avez
donné la parole à monsieur rabat cas
monsieur rebbah kébir
au moment même où les corps des
gendarmes étaient rapatriés sur notre
territoire
je sais bien que l'information à ses
règles je le comprends mais aussi des
limites
n'est ce pas nous avons affaire à des
gens qui sont les complices de
terroristes et d'assassins
de surcroît ce sont des gens qui n'ont
pas respecté les règles élémentaires de
l'hospitalité et ils ont l'air d'être
mécontent d'être chez nous mais qui
sommeille
s'ils veulent partir nous sommes tout à
fait prêts à faciliter leur départ si
c'est moi qui le prouvent qu'ils
trouvent un pays d'accueil et qu'ils
s'en aillent
est ce que vous comptez les expulser où
il ya un entre-deux sont les arrêtés
d'expulsion les concerne tous les 16 qui
sont affolants bresson touché le coup
d'un arrêté d'expulsion
la seule chose qui pour le moment ne
peut pas être faite puisqu'il n'est pas
question pour nous de les envoyer en
algérie où il je crains qu'il ne serait
assez mal accueillis ils risqueraient
leur vie donc il n'est pas question pour
nous de le faire
mais s'il trouve notre pays ma foi qui
dit rien on les entend pas il faut bien
que l'on sache que nous ne tolérerons
pas que sur notre sol s'organise où se
développent des réseaux de soutien au
terrorisme
dès mardi nous continuerons ce type
d'action chaque fois que cela sera
nécessaire précisément que reproche-t-on
précisément et directement aux personnes
qui sont à juin est réservé dans les
nations ou leur soutien direct à des
mouvements liés au terrorisme
c'est à dire mais ça suffit chez rien de
plus à dire
les décisions ont été prises par le
gouvernement c'est à dire par moi même
après en avoir discuté avec le premier
ministre et lui avoir présenté un
certain nombre de mesures
ces mesures ont été appliquées il y en
aura d'autres si c'est nécessaire mais
ce que ces personnes par exemple ont
directement participé au réseau
d'étudiants
je n'ai rien d'autre à vous dire vous
n'êtes pas juge d'instruction certaines
notamment et bien alors je n'ai rien
d'autre à vous dit mais si vous les
assigne à résidence et que vous avez des
choses précises à leurs proches et juin
ainsi que les là bien entendu on ne le
fait pas pour le plaisir
ces personnes étaient connus et
surveillés les services de police
d'autres sont dans le même cas
chaque fois que nous trouverons dans ce
type de situation nous agirons de même
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs des algériens
ou de ressortissants d'autres pays
lorsqu'on est en france on doit
respecter un minimum de règles et
notamment ne rien faire qui soit de
nature à porter atteinte d'une part à la
sécurité intérieure du pays ou aux
relations de la france avec d'autres
pays
c'est une situation inacceptable est ce
que d'autres interpellations qui ne sont
pas contents je le redis on ne les
retient parents ils peuvent partir est
ce que d'autres interpellations
pourraient avoir lieu dans les heures
les jours qui viennent on aura peut-être
d'autres si c'est nécessaire tout cela
sera fonction des circonstances
nous allons revenir avec vous monsieur
le ministre l'opération de police je
vous lise s est déroulé au même moment
un peu partout en france
a lyon c'est un imam qui a été
interpellé à paris également mais aussi
dans le nord voyez ce reportage de
benoît gadret notre correspondant
l'épicerie zitouni à liévin n'a plus de
patron depuis ce matin ahmed dit uni 46
ans a été interpellé par des
fonctionnaires des renseignements
généraux est assigné à résidence à la
caserne de folembray marié à une
française
ahmed zitouni vont un peu de tout dans
sa boutique notamment de l'alcool et de
la viande de porc
il a présenté par le ministère de
l'intérieur comme un militant islamiste
ce que récuse sa femme et ses amis je
rappelle qu'il n'a rien à voir
le fish n'avait plus le choix il ni
politique ni rien du tout moi je t'aime
ouvriers je vous dis je le connais il
n'a rien avoué il faisait pas de
politique en france
un autre homme originaire d'algérie
étaient visés par l'opération policière
dans la région nord
un père de famille qui séjourne depuis
20 ans en france dans ce quartier
périphérique de lille c'est sa femme qui
ce matin nous a ouvert la porte
est-ce qu'il a quelque chose à voir avec
le fils où était la prière unis sinon il
tournait cette affaire registre la
police est venue n'était pas là ce n'est
pas vrai il était partiellement
il faut dire que les policiers sont
venus à 8h30 alors que 17 heures les
radios annoncé la vague d'arrestations
selon sa famille
l'homme recherché est ce soir parti en
vacances est-ce que ça n'est pas aussi
une façon de dire aux français nous
faisons ce qu'il faut pour que des
choses n'arrive pas chez nous ce qui
arrive en algérie n'arrive pas chez nous
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de menaces
directes en france mais nous avons déjà
eu d'abord j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire il est normal que la france soit
dans une situation de fait ils ont vu ce
qui est arrivé en argentine dans un
autre domaine où à l'angleterre et par
conséquent devons savoir que la menace
terroriste existe partout n'existe pas
particulièrement chez nous mais elle
existe partout
par contre il faut bien être conscient
d'autre chose c'est que nous avons une
communauté musulmane très importante
dans notre pays pour le l'immense
majorité d entre elles la quasi-totalité
des musulmans sont des gens paisibles et
il faut bien comprendre que nous n'avons
non seulement nous avons aucune
hostilité envers la religion musulmane
nous avons du respect pour elle c'est
une des grandes religions du monde
cela étant sous couvert de la religion
un certain nombre de gens utilisent
c'est cette pratique ou se servent
d'elle trois réalités réparer ou
conduire des actions de noyautage de la
communauté musulmane afin de la pousser
dans les bras des intégristes que
représente exactement le front islamique
du salut en france ce sont des personnes
un petit nombre de personnes en
l'occurrence celles qui sont assignés à
résidence ou vous avez décrit toiles
sont plus grands notamment la découverte
des arts matériels seront plus
nombreuses on a bien vu qu'il peut y
avoir des réseaux que nous connaissons
pas aussi alors nous devons continuer à
surveiller ces milieux je le répète nous
devons faire en sorte que la communauté
musulmane est le même soit protégé que
tous ceux qui veulent pratiquer leur
religion puisse le faire à l'abri des
pressions des fanatiques mais nous
n'avons pas du tout l'intention surman
entretenait encore avec le premier
ministre
il y à une heure non pas du tout
l'intention de tolérer sur notre sol les
agissements de ceux qui abusent de
l'autre hospitalité pour se livrer des
actions de propagande contre la france
ou qui exemptent les assassinats et les
attentes à le considérer qu'il ya des
menaces d'attentât dans notre pays à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de menace
précise mais je le redis ces menaces
peuvent toujours existé en tous les cas
que nous appliquons un certain nombre de
mesures de sécurité ce qui est normal
c'est à dire vous comptez renforcer les
contrôles par exemple certainement
demain dans les jours qui viennent
ob vous le verrez bien ça ne doit
constituer une surprise pour tout le
monde pas dans ces redevances que nous
allons faire sont remis à ce que nous
devons donc il pourrait y avoir d un
renforcement des mesures de sécurité
précise emilie a d'ores et déjà en fond
de territoire français bienvenue et il y
a d'ores et déjà la sécurité c'est
évident très bien depuis le début de la
vague d'attentats au mois de septembre
de l'année dernière chaque fois que des
intérêts français ont été visés en
algérie le gouvernement a réagi par une
série d'interpellations sur le
territoire français un rappel signée
karl com
répondre vite et de manière
spectaculaire
voilà en quelques mots toute la
stratégie adoptée par les autorités
françaises face au terrorisme qui frappe
ses ressortissants en algérie une
stratégie mise en place à l'automne
dernier quelques jours seulement après
la libération de trois membres du
personnel de l'ambassade retenus en
otage à alger 88 islamistes algériens
sont interpellés dans plus d'une
vingtaine de départements français
parmi eux djaffar el-houari président de
la fraternité algérienne en france un
mouvement proche du fils bilan de ce
vaste coup de filet trois personnes
mises en examen
cette assigné à résidence dont djaffar
et loire est marqué les esprits mais
aussi tenter d'empêcher l'implantation
de réseau islamiste sur le sol français
suivra alors une série d'opérations la
plus importante aboutissants il ya une
quinzaine de jours à l'arrestation de
six militants présumés du fils
interpellé en possession d'armes à la
gare de perpignan après l'assassinât de
cinq français il y a deux jours les
autorités ont donc encore choisi de
répliquer au plus vite avec une nouvelle
assignation à résidence de neuf
militants islamistes manière de ne pas
abandonner le bras de fer qui oppose la
france aux terroristes algériens manière
aussi de rassurer l'opinion française en
lui donnant le sentiment que le
gouvernement a bien toutes les choses en
main
mais c'est parce que vous avez mis en
cause hier certains prisonniers dans tôt
notamment les états unis et l'allemagne
qui ont réagi assez assez vivement en
disant mais ces personnes là les
personnes qui sont chez nous et qui sont
présumés appartenir donc au front
islamique du salut n'ont rien fait de
délictueux sur notre territoire
si l'on considère que le fait pour un
pays ami lié de la france d'avoir sur
son territoire des personnes qui non
seulement ne désavoue pas les attentats
mais les cautionnent ne constitue pas un
acte de mariage inamicale et si l'on
considère que ces personnes ont le droit
de se livrer à ce type d'activité alors
je crains que ces pays ne se prépare à
un réveil douloureux
ce que je constate d'ailleurs c'est qu
en allemagne le ministre de l'intérieur
lui-même a fait appel de la décision de
droit d'asile qui avait été accordé dans
un land à monsieur rabah kebir
en ce qui concerne les états unis comme
l'angleterre
des démarches ont été faites aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement français je note au
passage par exemple que le cyanure adam
aux états unis a annoncé son ralliement
au gia le gia vient de revendiquer
l'assassinât de cinq français
ce que je disais et donc bien conforme à
la vérité ce sont des gens qui sont
complices des terroristes et des
assassins
rappelons que rien ne peut être reproché
sur sur le territoire de de ces pays si
et
on ne peut être rien leur reprocher sur
le territoire de ces pays sauf le
soutien qu'ils apportent des moments
terroristes qui ont assassiné
je leur rappelle en dehors de très
nombreux alger qu'on oublie et qui sont
tombées sur leurs sous leurs coups
quinze français ont été assassinés et 56
occidentaux alors si l'on considère que
ce n'est rien les etats-unis ont fait
l'expérience d'ailleurs eux mêmes de la
présence sur leur sol de terroristes
intégristes il croit donc qu'ils en sont
conscients le le droit d'asile est une
chose la complicité avec les
organisations terroristes mais une autre
j'ai donc le sentiment que nos amis
allemands comme nos amis anglais comme
nos amis américains prendront les
mesures qui s'imposent vous considérez
que vous n'avez pas empiéter sur le
domaine réservé aux chevaux ministre des
affaires étrangères par exemple en
prenant contact comme ça ou en lançant
des des informations en journée la
grande et d'autres pays
est ce que vous imaginez que les mesures
que je propose
ou que les propos que je tiens le sont
en fonction de ma seule inspiration du
moment
il y à un seul gouvernement en france il
y a un premier ministre
c'est donc avec lui que nous arrêtons
les décisions qui devraient être prises
tout ça mais pas le résultat d'une
foucades
d'ailleurs les dépêches qui ne sont pas
venus ce soir montre bien que nos
démarches ont été prises mais les
grincements de dents notamment à londres
qui a rejeté les métiers ne vous
dérangera autres mieux les grincements
de dents c'est un peu inévitable
personne n'a envie de se faire un peu je
dirais ont pas rappelés à l'ordre
mais se faire dire que il ne fait pas
tout à fait ce qu'ils devraient faire
en tous les cas je rappelle que lors du
dernier sommet européen le terrorisme a
fait partie des sujets qui ont été mis à
l'ordre du jour et que cela est
également inscrit à l'ordre du jour des
travaux qui vont
les ministres des affaires et des les
ministres de la justice et de
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
début septembre à berlin je souhaite
qu'il y ait davantage de coordination
nous avons été les premiers à alerter
nos collègues et amis sur les dangers
que représentait l'intégrisme et
l'utilisation de méthodes terroristes
je crois que maintenant tout le monde on
sera davantage conscients je reviens
d'un mot sur le travail de la police
française à l'heure actuelle est ce que
chaque fois qu'il y à un attentat en
algérie contre les intérêts français ou
contre les intérêts d'autres pays on va
comme ça assigné à résidence des gens
qui ont un rapport proche ou lointain
avec avec le front islamique du salut
ais et vite
éventuellement les expulsés lors nous
surveillons d'une manière permanente les
milieux qui sont liés et à l'intégrisme
et qui peuvent constituer autant
d'éléments de soutien du terrorisme
et lorsque cela est nécessaire nous
intervenons nous l'avons déjà fait
j'ajouterai que malheureusement quand
nous sommes arrivés au gouvernement nous
avons trouvé un pays dans lequel il y à
bien d'autres mouvements de terrain on
essaie d'implanter que les algériens
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire le gouvernement a conduit une
action en direction d'un mouvement kurde
d'autres d'autres mouvements peuvent
être à leur tour visé nous n'avons pas
du tout l'intention d'accepter ce type
de situation quant aux gens que nous
assignons résidence parce que les
arrêtés d'expulsion ne peuvent pas être
exécutée si nous trouvons demain pays
qu'ils veuillent les accueillir
nous sommes tout à fait prêts
naturellement à les laisser partir sinon
jusqu'à nouvel ordre il reste assigné à
résidence en resteront là combien de
temps le temps nécessaire à alger
maintenant l'attentât demain